[Musik]
kanzler olaf scholz hat sich heute zu
wort gemeldet er hat zum volk gesprochen
das klang alles andere als gut erschwert
uns alle auf schwere zeiten ein hören
wir doch einmal rein
sondern ich zynisch aber natürlich wäre
eine deckelung bei einem knappen gut ein
signal energie ist nicht wertvoll haut
raus was ihr wollt und das gegenteil
brauchen im moment effizienz
einsparungen und es sind gerade
handwerker sollen handwerker die dafür
sorgen dass diese effizienzmaßnahmen den
wir pumpen ausbau von solarpanelen und
so weiter umgesetzt werden das war jetzt
nicht olaf scholz aber robert habeck mal
erkennt bei beinamen war eigentlich
ähnlich wer redet diesen sich ziemlich
ähnlich aber dann zeigen das gleiche
nochmal trotzdem herzlich willkommen für
den nach acht meine gäste heute abend
sind ich freue mich sehr auf jeden
einzelnen es wird spannend fürstin
gloria von thurn und taxis ihr thema
heute abend deutschland wd
industrialisiert linken politikerin
sahra wagenknecht sie sagt schluss mit
den sanktionen und zur not müssen wir
auch gasmasken 2 beziehen
ex-regierungssprecher und deutschlands
kommunikationsprofi nummer eins plus da
ist natürlich das wichtigste filmnacht
stammgast béla anda hadert nicht mit der
korona politik sondern mit dem corona
kurs der regierung erfordert zurück zur
eigenverantwortung belebt den bürgern
das kommando last but not least
bestseller autorin gaby hauptmann es
positiv gestimmt sie hat ukrainische
flüchtlinge bei sich aufgenommen und
bringt heute ein positives starkes
plädoyer mit zufällen nach 8 und zwar
mit der schwarzmalerei es wird schwer
aber wir schaffen das meine erste frage
ist heute in die runde fürs team haben
sie ihr leben eigentlich auch schon
umgestellt
nein richtig umgestellt natürlich noch
nicht weil ich einfach immer sparsam mit
den ressourcen umgehen also bei mir zu
hause wird das licht ausgeschaltet
bei mir zuhause wird keine aircondition
laufen gelassen wenn die fenster offen
sind in warmen ländern hier in
deutschland braucht man ja gar keine
klimaanlage hier habe ich gar keine
klimaanlage also mit den ressourcen
sparsam umzugehen haben wir gelernt von
kinder auf und das ist das hat man
irgendwann in den knochen und dadurch
würde ich sagen sind wir zuhause öko
das ist ein gutes wort bela wir sind bei
dir aus
ja also ich habe tatsächlich
einmal sagen können das privileg das
glück ein kamin zu haben und ich habe
schwiegereltern die ganze zeit im winter
mit holz heizen nützlich und hab da
jetzt schon ihr holz gesichert ich weiß
nicht ob das nun besonders umweltgerecht
ist oder nicht aber wer weiß was kommt
und aus diesem grunde kann man sagen ja
ein bisschen umgestiegen bin ich das
schon frau wagenknecht ein gut
präpariert für schlechte zeiten wir
haben es ja gerade leider im film nicht
gehört aber herr scholz hat ja
eigentlich alle weil sie darauf
eingestimmt dass alle auch unterhaken
sollen und dass man sich schon mal auf
schwere zeiten einstellen soll ich finde
das wirklich zynisch also die die
bundestag sitzen das schließt mich ein
die können natürlich auch schwere zeiten
sich mehr oder minder leisten also wenn
der gaspreis explodiert und jetzt
empfohlen wird die leute sollten mal
vielleicht 2000 euro zurücklegen für die
nachzahlung und vielleicht sind auch
4000 ok bundestagsabgeordneter kann das
aber wer kann das sonst also ich finde
das wirklich unverantwortlich wie die
regierung sehenden auges in eine
gasknappheit hineinläuft die nicht sein
müsste also das muss man immer wieder
sagen das ist ja hausgemacht das sind ja
die sanktionen der eu und die reaktion
und russland darauf und ich meine das
wurde alles gemacht weil man gesagt hat
wie berbalk damals wir wollen russland
ruinieren und wir sehen jetzt wir holen
hier nicht russland wir ruinieren unser
wohlstand wir ruinieren unsere industrie
und russland hat sogar höhere einnahmen
als je zuvor also die sanktion für
putins taschen und hier im land sind die
portemonnaies lea und ich finde das ist
unerreicht können wir gleich weil es ja
auch die these die sie heute mitgebracht
haben aber freiheit meint er aber warum
wollen wir russland ruinieren es hat ja
wohl einen grund wir wollen ja menschen
schützen also ich habe keine leider
keine wärmepumpe machen weil es bei mir
nicht geht kann sich hieß es ich kann
meine ölheizung
subventioniert bekommen wenn ich auf gas
umstellen das hätte mich dann 15.000
euro gekostet die umstellung auf gas
gott sei dank gab es nicht gemacht ich
habe auch einen kamin einen offenen
kamin aber auch das ist problematisch
weil die ganzen ebene
das war ja gesichtern auch im gespräch
also dass unterhaken denke ich wir bei
uns einfach mal sehen und wenn man von
den leuten sprechen die mehr geld haben
im bundestag dann kann man da vielleicht
ein bisschen unter hagen indem man
menschen die rechts und links wurden da
einfach ein bisschen die eure
hauptmieter hartmann ich hoffe es ist in
ordnung man kann ja auch nachschauen wie
viele bücher sie verkauft haben sie 14
jahre als vermögende frau können sie
denn dann nachvollziehen dass frau
wagenknecht sagt na ja vielleicht auch
sie haben gut reden und vielleicht auch
frau nadija
was also hinduja persönlich was ich
versuche ich habe mal versucht vor
jahren etwas ins laufen zu bringen das
hieß mein kind an der hand nehmen das
wurde dann in der
baden-württembergischen stiftung
aufgenommen ich meinte es aber auch
wirklich so ich meine jeder von uns hat
nachbarn hat eine alte frau vielleicht
als nachbarin oder hat kinder als
nachbarn und jeder von uns sieht wenn es
gut geht und wen schlecht geht und es
tut uns nicht so wahnsinnig weh wenn wir
einfach dann da hingehen und denjenigen
wirklich unterhaken und sagen kann ich
irgendwo helfen das ist nämlich
eigentlich eine christliche
nächstenliebe pflicht wenn man über die
katholischen sie vollkommen recht aber
das ist nicht die politik muss dem
ganzen volk helfen und es einfach ganz
richtig was die frau wagen nicht sagt
unverantwortlich dass wir sehenden auges
in die verarmung der 80 millionen bürger
hat deutschland untersagt der chef
politiker der außenminister und der
wirtschaftsminister sagt er wird jetzt
weniger duschen das ist
das aller weniger ja auch wenn wir alle
anleger genau es ist einfach zu mischen
weil damit werden wir das problem nicht
in den griff kriegen deutschland ist ein
industrieland wir haben jetzt 40 jahre
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung und den
machen wir in wenigen jahren einfach
news will ich kaputt das sehe ich weil
wir eben die falsche entscheidung das
sehe ich nicht so sie haben ja gehen der
rigi hat den größten waldbesitzer im
größten waldbesitzer in deutschland ich
meine da kommt ja wirklich was zusammen
noch ist der deutschlands ist der staat
und sie bei gemeinden als in die 2 nein
ein oh wir kommen weit weit hinterher
wir sind waldbauern und wir müssen hart
arbeiten und dass wir geld verdienen der
staat und die gemeinden und die kommunen
können es sich leisten weil sie damit
steuergeld an tieren dass sie sie nicht
genau jeden pfennig umdrehen müssen das
ist bei uns privaten nicht der fall wir
müssen jeden pfennig und drinnen und das
arbeiten im wald wird uns immer
schwieriger gemacht weil die auflagen
die aus brüssel kommen was dürfen wir
ernten was dürfen wir pflanzen wie viele
mitarbeiter müssen wir mindestens haben
was für machine dürfen überhaupt den
einsatz kommen sie können sich nicht
vorstellen mit wie vielen beschränkungen
und auflagen wir arbeiten müssen und das
ist für den privaten faust extrem schwer
das glaube ich sofort wie viele
mitarbeiter haben sie dann im forst
haben insgesamt 50
insgesamt versorgt jetzt gab es gerade
die familienunternehmen hier die haben
auch gerade eine große tagung gehabt in
berlin und da waren war mein leitung von
martha beiden ganz genau da war
beispielsweise gruppe von trigema dabei
da war die frau doktor schmiede dabei
die hat die vielen schmieder kliniken
jahr 2800 angestellte da war auch dabei
als
arbeitgeberpräsident und und die sagten
dann okay unser problem ist energie gebe
ich ihnen recht aber unser problem sind
eben auch die arbeitskräfte die müssen
irgendwie rein kommen und bisher haben
wir schon so vieles geschafft auch das
schaffen wir noch also diese diese diese
schlecht sehr reif scheint mir für den
mittelständischen unternehmen den
familienbetrieben allerdings noch nicht
so frau sollte man ganz viele
unternehmen die ganz große angst haben
da sieht man wieder je nach dem film
entspricht aber lassen sie uns bevor wir
zu ihrem plädoyer kommen worauf ich mich
schon sehr freue erst mal zu frau
wagenknecht und man detailliert die
sanktionen besprechen in der sendung ja
also die uhr hat ja nachdem russland die
ukraine überfallen hat riesige
sanktionspaket auf den weg gebracht und
das ausdrückliche ziel dieser sanktionen
war putin unter druck zu setzen seien
verbrecherischen krieg zu beenden und
ich finde langsam ist es zeit der
wahrheit ins gesicht zu sehen und
festzustellen diese sanktionspolitik ist
leider komplett gescheitert sie hat
dieses ziel nicht nur nicht erfüllt
sondern sie in die andere richtung sie
ruiniert uns nicht russland wir haben
eine rekord inflation viele leute wissen
nicht mehr wie sie das lebensnotwendige
bezahlen sollen es gibt prognosen sollte
der gasfluss jetzt im juli ganz
ausbleiben dass die deutsche wirtschaft
im zweiten halbjahr um zwölf prozent
einbricht das über fünf millionen
industriearbeitsplätze bedroht sind in
einem halben jahr das sind zustände wie
in der weimarer republik und selbst wenn
es nicht so die so allerschlimmsten
kommt ganz viele betriebe denken ja
jetzt schon darüber nach nach einer
umfrage jeder fünfte dass die
betriebsteile arbeitsplätze ins ausland
verlagern weil es einfach in deutschland
bei den horrenden energiekosten nicht
mehr wirtschaftlich ist zu produzieren
so und das ist in russland die russische
wirtschaft funktioniert halbwegs normal
das heißt die inflation hat sich gerade
wieder geht gerade wieder etwas runter
das leben scheint weitgehend normal zu
sein die supermarkt regale sind gefüllt
die straßen sind voller staus und vor
allem die russischen einnahmen also der
staatshaushalt den man eigentlich
treffen wollte die sind höher ist je
zuvor weil die hohen preise natürlich
obwohl man weniger verkauft letztlich
bei putin mit zusätzlichen einnahmen zu
buche schlagen und ich muss ja wenn man
das konstatiert dann kann man doch nicht
sagen wir machen so weiter und auch das
ganze gerede über alternative
lieferanten für öl für gas das war doch
heiße luft wir haben keine alternativen
lieferanten wir haben sie bei öl nicht
und wir haben sie kurzfristig auch bei
gas nicht das hat sich alles zerschlagen
was habe eckdaten vorgeschlagen hat oder
was habe ich in aussicht gestellt hat
und deswegen finde ich muss man in der
situation ganz klar sagen dieser
wirtschaftskrieg ist gescheitert wir
sollten die sanktionen aufheben würden
wir keine anderen lieferanten haben dann
bitteschön kaufen wir russisches öl und
gas so viel wie wir halt brauchen für
unsere wirtschaft wir treiben mit vielen
ländern handel die kriege führen die die
menschenrechte missachten und mit füßen
treten zum beispiel in den golfstaaten
wo also homosexuelle hingerichtet
während frauen gesteinigt werden wenn
wir mit allen ländern unseren handel
unterbinden wollten die sich nicht so
verhalten wie wir oder wie wir uns das
wünschen ja dann werden wir müssen wir
also mehr oder weniger unseren handel
auf die europäische union oder selbst da
wäre es teilweise schwierig also
insoweit finde ich es ist eine völlig
falsche politik ich finde es
verantwortungslos dass die regierung
diesen weg weitergeht und mit
irgendwelchen wohl fallen
energiespartipps aufwartet stadt das
problem an der wurzel zu lösen wir
bräuchten keinen notstand zu haben wir
könnten die energie beziehen die wir
brauchen und ich finde wir sollten das
wirklich tun das ist die regierung
eigentlich das hat sie mit ihrem amtseid
geschworen nämlich schaden vom deutschen
volk abzuwenden soll sie jetzt bitte
einlösen schluss mit den sanktionen und
kaufen wir die energie die wir brauchen
damit wir wieder normal leben keine
frage und putin gehen wir hin und sagen
okay wir machen das diplomatische
schröder hat es probiert er wird sich
nicht aus dieser ukraine zurückziehen er
sich sein ziel
wenn er sogar dadurch aber danach so
eine bessere idee der lacht samt remote
über uns ja wir haben eine bessere idee
ja wir haben eine sehr gute idee wir
müssen das allerwichtigste ist dass wir
darüber nachdenken was ist für die
ukrainischen bürger das beste
wie können wir den ukrainern am besten
helfen genau und und da gehen die
meinungen natürlich auseinander denn der
deutsche idealismus sagt
gerechtigkeit wir müssen den ukrainern
so viele waffen wie möglich geben damit
sie sich gegen die bösen russen
verteidigen können aber das wissen wir
als mütter wenn wir streiten die kinder
haben dass wir die streitenden die netze
erstmal auseinander nehmen müssen und
dann müssen wir verhandeln oder sagt er
hat angefangen und so ist es bei großen
leuten auch das heißt würden würden sie
putin und die ukraine mit streiten
kindern vergleichen also jeder streit
zwischen erwachsenen zwischen völkern
alles was auf der welt passiert können
sie in miniatur in einer familie
beobachten das ist also die marco di
marco sicht und ich denke immer wie
könnte man denn der ukraine am besten
helfen und ich habe von anfang an gesagt
deutschland sie sehen punkten aber auch
als den angreifer wien bösen bruder der
dem anderen einfach eine reihe na sowas
gemacht hat genau aber ich sage das
interessiert mich gar nicht mich
interessiert das ukrainische volk und
ich möchte dass das ukrainische volk das
land nicht zerstört wird wir dürfen eine
sache nicht vergessen die amerikanische
militärdoktrin ist nach wie vor die der
flexible response und das habe ich aus
diesem fantastischen buch von klaus von
dohnanyi der nämlich dass das mit dem
titel nationale interessen und diese
flexible response bedeutet dass die
verteidigung und das kriegsgeschehen
immer in dem land des opfers stattfindet
also das angegriffene land und dass man
dieses angegriffene land womöglich bis
zu seiner zerstörung
dass man die zerstörung
in kauf nehmen muss hawaii ist flexible
response das ist militärdoktrin der
amerikaner müssen gleich ein großer
anhänger ihres pragmatismus aber auch
leutnant der reserve wie wahrscheinlich
viele aus ihrem freundeskreis ebenso
insofern weiß ich auch was flexible
response und wahrscheinlich hat klaus
von dohnanyi das so aufgeschrieben
flexible response bedeutet eigentlich
dass man auf eine eine
dagegen eine 1 nicht nur drogen sondern
ein krieg sagt des gegners flexibler
reagiert das heißt man kann sogar wenn
man auf die nukleare ebene geht mit
taktischen oder mit
mittelstreckenraketen damals war das so
oder mit strategische nuklearraketen
antworten also dieses diese diese form
auf eine bedrohung oder auf einen
angriff mit einem nicht nur angemessen
sondern einem eskalierenden mittel oder
mit einem anderen mittel antworten zu
können das ist eigentlich bisher aber im
land des angegriffenen statt das findet
im land des opfers das opfer die
flexible response findet in der ukraine
statt und deswegen sage ich wäre mein
plädoyer diese
waffenlieferungen und vor allen dingen
das was die eben heilige friedenspartei
die grünen die haben am lautesten
gefordert schweres gerät in die ukraine
aber damit schaden wir doch den ukraine
denn solange der krieg angeheizt wird
mit mehr waffen wird es niemals zur ruhe
kommen aber all das ist doch überhaupt
gar kein ich mein wollen sie hingehen
und diplomatisch das wurde doch alles
versucht es wurde ja mehrfach wurden ja
politiker haben es versucht mit putin
dass irgendwie zu regeln wollen sie
jetzt selber in die ukraine gehen und
sagen okay
als als männer freund als auch nicht als
schuldige laut honda männer freund von
herrn putin normalerweise sagt man immer
diese männer auf kameradschaft das
bewirkt was uns gesagt wir glauben ja
nicht ernsthaft wirklich nicht ernsthaft
dass das dass wir da irgendetwas
ausrichten können indem wir da hingehen
und und sage jetzt jetzt sag mal
friedlich miteinander wie man das mit
kindern wir nicht ich glaube dass wir
schon was ausrichten könnten also wie er
heißt jetzt eigentlich vor allem die
vereinigten staaten der west also wurde
der westen insgesamt ich meine ich fand
interessant vor kurzem ist ja hat das
editorial board der new york times einen
sehr guten artikel geschrieben und sie
haben beiden dafür kritisiert dass er im
grunde die ukraine geradezu verdonnert
hat nicht kompromissbereit zu sein und
sie haben dort gesagt wenn wir diesen
kurs weiter fahren also wenn die us
regierung diesen kurs weiterfährt dann
riskieren sie eine unglaubliche
eskalation bis hin eben auch zur
ausweitung des krieges auf ganz europa
und es müsste jetzt endlich mal muss
sich von unrealistischen kriegs zielen
verabschieden und ähnlich hat sich
kissen ja auch geäußert in davos also es
gibt ja schon immer mehr stimmen und ich
glaube das sind aber jetzt gern ganz
großes interview auch gegeben und da hat
accenture beispielsweise gesagt gehabt
dass natürlich die territorien da hat er
sich in davos auf missverstanden gefühlt
wohl dass die territorien die zur
ukraine gehört haben inklusive der krim
sollten auch zurück an die ukraine und
dass er schon auch für die sanktionen
ist aber man muss den korridor aufhalten
weil kissen ja auch sagt russland also
europa kann er sich nicht ohne russland
vorstellen ist weil immer ein wichtiger
partner und die frage ist ja auch jahre
dass sie jetzt nicht also dass man jetzt
nicht sagt die gehören zu russland okay
aber man muss sie erstmal ausklammern
also weil es ist ja nicht realistisch
dass sie zurück erobert werden
militärisch sondern wir jetzt eigentlich
nur die wahl dass das alles ungerecht
ist ist überhaupt keine frage aber die
frage ist ja was was will man was will
man will man jetzt einen jahrelang
stellungskrieg wo jeden tag menschen
sterben wo eine stadt nach der nächsten
zerstört wird oder hat man zunächst mal
ein korridor die hatten ja schon mal
verhandelt sie waren auch relativ weit
und da haben nicht die russen sich
zurückgezogen das waren ja diese
istanbuler verhandlungen sondern hat sie
lenski sich zurückgezogen also ist man
bereit zu sagen wir klammern das erst
mal aus wir machen ein waffenstillstand
letztlich war ein konflikt immer die
frage der nato-mitgliedschaft wir machen
da kompromisse und versuchen dann
langfristig irgendwie einen gemeinsamen
korridor zu finden sei es dass die auch
einfach die bevölkerung dort gefragt
wird diese abstimmen was sie möchte oder
so das sind ja alles wege aber dafür
müssen erst mal die waffen schweigen und
ich glaube diese bereitschaft muss man
haben während wenn man jetzt sagt also
wir kämpfen bis wir alles zurückerobert
haben dann wird dieser krieg ähnlich
weiter waren richtig interessiert das
wirklich wo sehen sie bei dem ein
beispiel wo sehen sie aktuell die
kompromissbereitschaft bei wladimir
putin wissen sie nämlich was mich
gewundert als schröder hingereist ist
habe ich gedacht okay putin mag ihn ja
der wirt den letzten menschlichen
korridor geben zumindest damit schröder
jetzt nicht als kompletter versager
zurück in sein land muss den ball sind
freunde und putin hat jetzt auch die
chance sich kompromissbereit zu zeigen
ist nichts passiert und da habe ich
schon gedacht okay er gibt ihm nicht mal
einen menschlichen körper oder irgendwas
möglichkeit gewesen und ich frage mich
halt ab und an schon wie wir überhaupt
davon ausgehen können dass putin
kompromissbereit ist oder dass er
wirklich nicht weitergehen will als die
ukraine es gibt ja auch experten die
davon ausgehen dass putin nicht schluss
machen wird mit der nahrung wo er wird
auch wieder die ukraine jetzt verlassen
sondern es geht darum dass wir ja erst
dann austesten können wie
kompromissbereit putin ist wenn wir
selber kompromissbereit sind also wenn
man in eine solche verhandlung reingeht
mit einem kompromissangebot erst dann
wissen wir wie weit die russen einen des
controllings angebot aussehen sollen wir
jetzt sagen okay ihr kriegt diesen
korridor dann dann bauen wir eben auch
wieder alles auf was total schön
zerstört hat sind ja jetzt schon die
verhandlungen und dann hat er praktisch
an land in der ukraine also mir kommt es
so vor als würden da gab und so erkennen
dass der donbass jetzt irgendwie zu
russland gehören sondern es geht darum
die gebiete auszuklammern das war das
was man damals in istanbul verhandelt
aber ausklammern bedeutet auch sagen wir
der status dieser gebiete bleibt offen
aber die ukraine macht zum beispiel das
angebot nato-mitgliedschaft darauf
verzichten wir das war ja immer der
streit apfel das war jetzt der soldat
minsk 192 arena so war wie eine art
minsker abkommen so und man fragt am
ende die menschen selber das kann man ja
auch und zwar international
beaufsichtigt also die referenten die es
bisher gab die gab es ja die waren
natürlich nie unter internationaler
aufsicht wenn man die leute fragt und
das wird beaufsichtigt wäre das ja auch
ein durchaus nachvollziehbares resultat
und ich finde ja nur der ausgangspunkt
worüber wir geredet haben waren ja die
sanktionen und ich glaube egal wie
dieser krieg weitergeht eines muss man
doch konstatieren die sanktionen ändern
an dem krieg nichts da die sanktionen
setzen putin auch nicht unter druck oder
oder unter druck zwang im gegenteil also
wie gesagt sie haben die einnahmen von
russland erhöht das heißt die sanktionen
sind auf jeden fall kein mittel das ist
finde ja erst einmal feststellen auch
andere andere stimmen und auch andere
experten wie beispielsweise auch sagen
die sanktionen müssen länger wirken und
zum beispiel beispielsweise der
ausschluss aus dem bankensystem der hat
schon auch wirkung gezeigt das problem
ist wohl hat mir auch ein experte gesagt
gab putin interessiert es nicht wie es
dem normalen bürger wird in russland auf
jeden fall ist das von manchen die
meinung und unruhen ist es noch nicht
angekommen also ich habe auch von
normalen bürgern also ich kenne
persönlich also leute die da familie
haben und die haben wir gesagt das leben
des relativ normal also natürlich ist
sind die lebensmittel teurer geworden
sind überall auf der welt teurer
geworden die gehobene mittelschicht die
früher mehr reisen konnte nach europa
die kann das nicht mehr aber der
einfache normale bürger der konnte
sowieso nicht reisen das heißt für den
hat sich relativ wenig verändert und die
wirtschaft läuft nach wie vor halbwegs
rund also es ist nicht so spürbar und je
länger die zeit vergeht ich halte das
für eine völlige illusion dass sie ihre
dass die sanktionen würden desto länger
hat ja auch putin zeit sich umzustellen
und es ist ja so man hat uns immer
erzählt russland sei international
isoliert das stimmt nicht der größte
teil der welt beteiligt sich nicht an
den sanktionen und deswegen kann
russland seine energie vor allem auch
sein öl seine kohle ganz ohne probleme
in andere regionen berlin iranian und
teilweise machen wir ja eine idiotie
also welche russisches öl geht jetzt
massiv nach indien wird in indien
verarbeitet und geht dann natürlich viel
viel teurer zurück nach europa das heißt
wir kaufen jetzt ist das zu diesel
verarbeitete russische öl aus indien
zahlen dafür einen horrenden preis weil
wir ja nicht das russische öl aus
russland kaufen wollen völlig verrückt
oder es werden teilweise natürlich auch
leitungen umdeklariert also schiffe auf
hoher see halten den radar aus
deklarieren die ladungen importieren wir
bei allen letzteres ist alle länder die
sanktioniert wurden haben sich diese
frachter irgendwo von mehr getroffen
haben
wir wieder zurück in der familie diese
aktion ist die mutti bestraft die kinder
und jetzt hört man auch da wieder die
psychologie bringen diese strafen was
die kinder wollen drogen nehmen wenn ich
die jetzt bestrafe und einsperren und
fernsehverbot unsicher machen sie sich
noch mehr so viel besser ist man spricht
mit ihnen vielleicht können wir doch auf
eine therapie zu sprechen ich will damit
nur sagen sanktionen sind das falsche
mittel das sehen wir in iran das sieht
man übrigens auch in vielen anderen
ländern die in sanktioniert wurden über
jahrzehnte nehmen sie kuba
das ist absolutes falsche mittel ich
finde wir sollten noch mal das
ukrainische volk in den vordergrund
rücken und fragen ist es richtig dass
wir einen krieg des westens gegen
russland auf ukrainischem boden mit
ukrainischen soldaten die für uns
kämpfen damit wir den russen in die knie
zwingen ist das richtig und wollen wir
dass die russen sind unsere kulturell
unsere brüder ich kann als aristokratin
sagen meine mutter meine großmutter ist
eine russische großfürstin ich habe in
der familie viele verwandte das haus
hessen wir haben unsere prinzessinnen
nach russland geschickt die dort die
zarin katharina die große ist eine
anhalt-zerbst wir sind kulturell mit den
russen verwandt wir dürfen uns nicht von
unseren brüdern und unseren starken
harmonischen mit großer dankbarkeit
verbunden
wir wollen hier auch gar nicht sagen ich
glaube dass mir niemand am tisch dass
jetzt alle russen schuld sind an diesem
krieg weil diese haltung jener die ist
ja schon herausragend anders das muss
man einfach sagen erfordert auch viel
mut nur wir sagen das einfach so locker
hier aber was war wagenknecht dass auch
sie fürs denn je sagen ist ja nicht der
mainstream sondern jeder der eine solche
äußerung macht am tag wird ja beschossen
auf den sozialen netzwerken als putin
verstehe rinn als russland freundin
gebrandmarkt und das muss man auch erst
mal aushalten deswegen im sinne der
freien meinungsäußerung respekt davor
wenn sie frau wagenknecht sind ja heute
noch ein bisschen weiter gegangen und
haben gemeinsam mit klaus ernst
gefordert das nord stream 2 wieder
angefahren wird dann geben wir so ein
bisschen drüber hinweg hier was zu einer
ja ich weiß einige paten reaktion von
verschiedenen mitgliedern ihrer partei
ihrer fraktion geführt hat und bis hin
zu jeder fahrer reagiert marx der gesagt
hat das ist nicht die position der
linken also so ganz konkurrent ist das
auch innerhalb ihres politischen lagers
nicht ja ich kann das auch erläutern
also warum ich jetzt zwei überhaupt ins
gespräch gebracht habe also wenn wir
jetzt sagen wir haben keine anderen
lieferanten oder es ist norwegen hat
gesagt 2024 können sie mehr liefern
katar hat gesagt
2026 vielleicht und dann zu schlimmen
konditionen und selbst die us fracking
industrie hat auch also eigentlich klar
gemacht also kurzfristig gibt es da
nicht genug also haben wir nur die wahl
wir gehen sehenden auges in den
gas-notstand und wirken unsere
wirtschaft ab und wir sitzen nimmt im
kalten oder wir kaufen russisches gas
und zwar so viel wie wir brauchen so und
dann gibt es ja bei notz dem einst ein
tatsächliches problem als natürlich hat
tut ihnen das jetzt politisch genutzt
und die lieferungen auch deshalb
reduziert weil er ja auf den
wirtschaftsweg reagiert aber es gibt ja
ein objektives problem das ist diese
turbine die das hat ja siemens auch
bestätigt kanada gewartet wird ganz
regulär und die die aber nicht
zurückschicken weil das ja unter die
sanktionen fällt das high stakes
ausschöpfen sagt es geht auch ohne die
turbinen aber nicht mit voller leistung
habe ich also ich bin ein techniker ich
weiß es nicht auf jeden fall ist es
glaube ich schon so vielleicht hätten
sie nicht auf 40 prozent reduzieren
müssen vielleicht hätten sie auch 60
liefern können aber volle leistung bei
nordstream 1 geht zurzeit nicht dann
gibt es noch eine pipeline die geht
durch polen die ist sowieso interessant
da haben wir früher auch gas bekommen
und jetzt ist es seit weihnachten so
dass deutschland polen gas verkauft also
unsere straße speicher werden ja voll da
wenn wir nicht seit weihnachten die
pipeline umgekehrt beliefern wollen
würden weil polen wollte kein gas mehr
aus russland bezieht deswegen seither
gas aus deutschland russisches gas was
wir über nord zu dem einst bekommen und
sie sind jetzt ganz unabhängig von
russland aber die gasspeicher in polen
sind voll unserer halt nicht dass die
jamal-pipeline so heißt sie die läuft
zurzeit auch nicht und dann ist nur noch
die pipeline durch die ukraine digital
durchs kriegsgebiet das heißt wenn wir
gas kaufen wollten brauchen wir
pipelines und die eine die nord nimmt
zwei liegt halt da am boden ist fertig
und könnte theoretisch frei geschaltet
werden also mir geht es nicht um nord
stream zwei mir geht es darum dass wir
irgendwie das problem lösen müssen dass
wir nicht im herbst entweder
industrieanlagen kaputt machen die gehen
ja nicht die die sind ja dann hinüber
also wenn die chemische industrie nicht
ausreichend gas hat sind
milliardenschwere anlagen im eimer oder
umgekehrt die haushalte auch nicht in
eine situation bringen dass plötzlich
der vermieter festlegen kann es wird nur
noch auf 16 oder 18 grad geheizt das
heißt ja jetzt im bundestag beschlossen
worden dass jetzt die regierung quasi
dekretieren kann haushalte werden nicht
mehr richtig geheizt oder warmem wasser
fließt nur noch zu wenigen tagen sind
sie politisch doch so erfahren und auf
der an- und und und und erwägen hier
erwecken den eindruck das wäre alles
ganz einfach wenn er weg nur über seinen
energiepolitischen schatten und frau
berbalk über ihre humanistische
außenpolitik richtlinie nicht aber mit
großen anfangs springen wird und sagen
wohin kommt setzt uns anderen tisch
machen wer wir sind doch eingebunden in
das nato system
die sich alle zuletzt vor einer woche
stein und bein geschworen haben diesen
aggressoren sich entgegen system da ist
es doch völlig undenkbar dass wir ein
alleingang machten aber andere machen
das auch die türkei macht einen vollen
alleingang dieser beteiligt sich
komplett nicht an den sanktionen
da sind zwei pipelines die in die türkei
gehen diesen voll ausgelastet und
dadurch sagte wagenknecht auch hierfür
seliger türkei als vorbild nehmen auch
ungarn beteiligt sich nicht an den
sanktionen also es gibt eine reihe von
ländern die sich nicht an den sanktionen
beteiligen und mir egal was die türkei
macht und was bürgern möchte dass wir
unser land nicht ruinieren oder genau
und wie es geht ist auch für unsere
pflicht als deutsche dass wir weil wir
klein sind und weil wir ja komplett
abhängig sind von der usa dir als
nato-chef über unsere außenpolitik
sicherheitspolitik bestimmen dass willi
beeinflussen das und das tut ja der
kanzler auch und das tut ja auch die
verteidigungsministerin und da wäre mein
plädoyer an die medien dass sie bitte
den bundeskanzler und und diese die
leute die sich ein bisschen auch
besonnen zeigen und nicht blatak taschen
sind sondern dass sie ein bisschen
zurückreisen
da wollen wir jetzt keinen da müssen sie
jetzt nach das problem ist dass die die
medien treiben die politiker vor sich
her die politiker sind darauf angewiesen
gewählt zu werden und sie glauben dass
das was in der zeitung steht der wille
des volkes ist und damit hätten sie
diese leute in die falsche richtung ich
habe es so geschätzt dass die
verteidigungsministerin helme geschickt
hat dabei hätte ihr einen orden
man hätte einen orden geben müssen
oder besser hängen aber passt das nicht
gesehen haben aber sie sagt er helme
mehr geht nicht dann heißt es schwitzen
mehr geht nicht aus
dann heißt es der gepard mehr geht nicht
und jede woche heißt dass irgendwas
kommt hinterher mehr geht nicht das ist
natürlich kein wissen
wir gerne zu ihrer these nein so benning
heute ich liebe das wir alle thesen
müssen dran kommt sehen wir heute auch
die these mit gebracht bevor sie angst
haben soll er hinein gehen erstmal warum
sind wir abhängig die frage lautete
lieber war warum haben nun zu abhängig
gemacht ja weil das das spiel der
globalisierung ist der witz der
globalisierung ist dass man überall das
kauft wo es am billigsten ist sonst gebe
es bei tk maxx keine jeans für 20 euro
wir hätten ja auch erwähnen in meinem
beispielsweise früher
stabilisierungen nicht gut findet das
kann ich verstehen aber wir haben die
letzten 30 jahre globalisierung nicht
die strategie von jetzt auf gleich
umdrehen wenn wir uns langsam aus der
globalisierung verabschieden weil wir
sagen es kann nicht sein dass die
chinesen unsere antibiotika herstellen
wie wir jetzt in der pandemie gesehen
haben es kann nicht sein dass
bangladesch jeans produziert die nur 5
euro kosten die wir dann bei dicker max
für 20 verkaufen es ist nicht richtig
wenn wir die globalisierung langsam dann
machen wir uns auch nicht mehr so
abhängig dann können wir auch an die
deutschen gasspeicher rangehen aber das
dauert jahre jetzt sind wir in einem
globalisierten dorf jetzt müssen wir
sind wir und wo man denken ja gewinnen
umdenken wir kommen gern nach dänemark
der in den markt hat biogasanlagen die
haben 25 prozent haben die ihr eigenes
gas und können damit ihre wärme erzeugen
25% warum weil die 19 anlagen haben in
dänemark und von überall her die
wirtschaftlichen die
landwirtschaftlichen erzeugnisse erholen
und auch was die industrielle abfälle
hat was lebensmittelmärkte an abfällen
hat und damit und damit bei 25 prozent
sind und waren kleine auswahl an 2400
jahr da machen halt einfach mehr was war
bei uns mit dem biogas anlagen bei uns
konnte jeder kleine land wird das haben
bei sich was hat er gemacht der hat
misst gebracht und alles und hat das
damit gefüttert hat nicht gereicht dann
mais angebaut dann gras angebaut das mag
ist kein just really ich sehe aber keine
rolle wir könnten aber mal voraus
schauen wir sind wir sind eigentlich wir
haben einfach nur gedacht okay monopol
das war natürlich auch die letzte
regierung muss ja auch wirklich sagen
muss man auch sagen wir haben einfach
gepennt das ist einfach aus politik ist
ja nicht ersehen einer merkel eine
richtung gelaufen also ich glaube
einfach nur in alle hier völlig zustimme
langfristig müssen wir ja auch aus den
fossilen energien raus überhaupt keine
sage dann werde ich mir abhängig nur es
gibt da technologisch immer noch eine
ganze reihe von ungelösten problemen
also ich finde auch dass wir deutlich
unbürokratischer zum beispiel
solardächer fördern könnten also ich
kenne jetzt aus dem persönlichen
bekanntenkreis sie wollen jetzt ein
solardach es ist sowas von kompliziert
und in deutschland das ist in anderen
ländern viel leichter also natürlich
könnte man viel mehr machen nur das
rettet unseren nächsten winter nicht wir
und müssen wir haben eben auch der
vorgänger und auch einen unterschied
deutschland ist eines der länder in
europa mit einer sehr sehr starken
industrie das ist unser wohlstandsmodell
also bei uns sieht es eben nicht aus wie
in nord lb in nordengland oder wie im
rest bild von den usa so zum glück sieht
es bei uns nicht aus auch italien hat
sehr viel der industrialisierten
regionen
und ich meine wir müssen das mit aller
kraft verhindern dass auch bei uns eine
große die industrialisierung hat findet
und ich meine auch weil sie vor in die
nato genannt haben die usa hat eine ganz
andere interessen lage also der gaspreis
in europa ist zurzeit neun mal so hoch
wie der in den usa das heißt die usa
machen natürlich irgendwo auch eigene
wirtschaftspolitik weil ihr standort
wird viel attraktiver dadurch wenn bei
uns die ex die energiekosten durch die
decke gehen und ich habe selber in
meinem umkreis wo ich wohne in merzig
macht gerade ein traditionsunternehmen
dicht villa & boch nämlich die fliesen
fabrik weil sie sagen sie können sich
das nicht mehr leisten und die geht zum
beispiel die türkei deswegen hatte ich
die vorhin erwähnt da ist es eben viel
billiger 200 leute die wieder ihren job
verlieren weil die arbeit des schlechter
bezahlt werden das auch aber das war
nicht sagen da konnte ich meine dieses
werk ist seit ewigen zeiten da audi in
die arbeiter bei unserem immer besser
verdient als in der türkei sondern es
ist jetzt die energiekosten differenz
die den ausschlag gegeben hat und so
gibt es eben ganz viele unternehmen und
ich finde da muss man einfach auch
pragmatische politik machen aber ich
kann so lange haben sie ja völlig recht
aber langfristig brauchen wir halt und
dir einmal das gedankenspiel würde ich
gerne mal mit ihnen beiden einmal
durchspielt sagen wir jetzt ich will
jetzt nicht anfangen und was alles
schlimmes in der ukraine passiert ich
finde dass das immer etwas schwieriger
debatte deswegen spielen wir mal das
gedankenspiel deutschland sagt jetzt die
sanktionen sind vorüber würde putin denn
dann und sofort die 40 prozent gas auch
wiedergeben oder man muss ja auch
überlegen wie meine rhetorisch handelt
aber letztens eine spannende kolumne ich
glaube es war herr fleischhauer der
geschrieben hatte ja was was herr scholz
und er putin da so reden was es für ein
signal auch gibt also wie würde das
jetzt ablaufen das frage ich hat welches
signal würden wir auch herr putin geben
wenn deutschland jetzt zurück weicht
also wie könnt ihr das alles
funktionieren auch die kommunikation
zurückweicht also ich meine es ist so
die eu hat den wirtschaftskrieg putin
hat den krieg in der ukraine begonnen
keine frage und das ist verbrecherisch
das ist glaube ich
wir haben darauf reagiert indem wir
einen immensen wirtschaftskrieg losen
getreten haben auf dem dann wiederum
auch russland schon wieder reagiert hat
und uns aber russland hat nicht den
wirtschaftskrieg begonnen und es ist
sehr unwahrscheinlich dass sie ihn von
sich aus führen würden also wenn wir
sagen die die sanktionen sind vorbei
also zum beispiel in deutschland jetzt
sagen würde ok werden lassen zur not
über nord stream 2 liefern dass wir
natürlich
auch so was er will er macht ja was er
will also der krieg wird keinen tag
früher beendet wenn wir die sanktionen
aufrecht erhalten das müssen wir uns
einfach klar machen wir wenn du dann
beendet auch gehören die waffen zu
liefern julie julia
heißt der dem krieg benzin zu geben den
krieg anzuheizen ich verstehe nicht wo
die deutschen die friedliebenden
deutschen die friedenspartei warum wir
nicht deeskalieren in hamburg an den
großen g 7 treffen durften die
polizisten keine hält betragen dann habe
ich gefragt warum ja das ist die
deeskalationsstrategie
riss die arme polizistin einem backstein
am kopf gekriegt hat dann durften sie
wieder helm getragen hier wäre die
deeskalationsstrategie angesagt aber
nein er würde nur davon die amerikaner
verkaufen fleißig waffen wir haben nicht
so viele wir werden beschimpft aber
verteidigungsministerin wird beschimpft
obwohl sie sehr klug gehandelt hat unser
kanzler wird beschimpft dass er nicht
sagt reden ist silber schweigen ist gold
also ich würde sagen mit diesem
besonderen kanzler haben wir sogar glück
wir müssen sagen dass wie sie richtig es
ist illusorisch wir haben als deutsche
nicht zu reden wir können nur versuchen
unseren einfluss geltend zu machen in
der groß politischen lage und unser
ansprechpartner bitteschön ist
washington und nicht moskau denn es ist
washington die russland in die knie
ziehen wolken bringen wollen und dafür
muss die ukraine erhalten und die
ukrainischen kämpfer müssen diesen es
hat eine abmachung jedoch selber der
südamerikaner folgenden beispiel gesagt
sie gehen in eine kneipe rein ein
amerikaner sieht mike tyson und er
möchte den mike tyson er hat ein
hühnchen mit ihm zurufen möchte ihm eine
rein schlagen traut sich aber nicht
sondern sagt den drei anderen männern
sie sollen ihm zeigen wie stark er ist
das ist der krieg in der ukraine und das
finde ich nicht gut und deswegen muss
frankreich und deutschland mit
engelszungen auf die amerikaner ein
reden und sagen leute wir kommen so
nicht weiter so im leben sie und auf dem
kühler teur liegt chinesen wir haben
russland in die arme der chinesen
getrieben ohne not das nachforschungen
aber die chinesen sind doch eine
weltmacht aber das ist das ist unser
sagen wir mal dass du worüber wir
nachdenken sollten aber doch nicht
russen und zu blocken sind gar nicht in
eine frage stellt immer wenn leute hier
sehr stark für sanktionen waren und für
waffenlieferungen habe ich immer gefragt
ob sie auch an die front gehen würden
weil wenn man für das alles ist muss man
ja auch für den krieg seien würden sie
denn wenn sie jetzt sagen keine
sanktionen und auch keine
waffenlieferung wäre dann auch für sie
in ordnung dass wir deutschen eigentlich
dann kein anteil daran nehmen beide
ukraine garcia das was die vollmacht so
viel wie möglich ukraine aufnehmen und
den ukrainern die möglichkeit geben hier
zu arbeiten
ich hatte nämlich vor zwei jahren eine
ukrainerin bei mir eine sehr fleißige
richter glauben sie dass die bei uns
eine arbeitsgenehmigung bekommen haben
miert haha ich konnte die arme dame
nicht anstellen die war tüchtig dann
habe ich den helmut schmidt im fernsehen
gesehen eine alte aufnahme da sagt er
nämlich selber er würde dringend raten
wenn wir arbeitskräfte brauchen wir nun
brauchen sie aber die alte aus rheine
holen und nicht ausgeschlossen weil die
ukraine uns kulturell näher sind und
dass weniger konfliktstoff bringt also
soweit
aber was in dem land passiert gebt uns
deutsche nichts an wenn ich sie sehr
salopp nein würde auch wiederaufbau
selbstverständnis wieder auf farben man
muss natürlich auch da helfen know how
liefern wir haben als deutsche sehr viel
know how und wir haben vor allen dingen
als deutsche unsere pflicht der
diplomatie wir haben unseren bruder die
franzosen die sind noch viel bessere
diplomaten an sich und die sarkozy und
angela merkel haben damals george hw
bush 2008 in bukarest gesagt wenn sie
und das wurde damals beschlossen dass
die ukraine teil der nato wird wenn die
ukraine teil der nato wird rasch einige
schlossen entschlossen jetzt steht die
in der ukrainischen verfassung der hand
hat angela merkel und sarkozy gesagt das
ist eine kriegserklärung an russland
2008 wie viel wasser ist die donau
runter geflossen das wollte der westen
nicht hört die haben gedacht der russe
ist schwach den krieg war schon an die
haben die haben ja schon das ist diese
idee fix dass man die russen
fertigmachen macht und das sehe ich
nicht rein weil das nicht gegen ihre
bleibe verloren
verwöhnen macht der varroa frau merkels
politik sagen dass sie die russen fertig
machen wollen das sieht sie hat ja
gesagt ja sie hat sich bei george stabil
bush nicht durchsetzen können mit
sarkozy weil sie beide gesagt haben es
ist keine gute idee die ukraine ist ein
brücken land es soll neutral bleiben vor
dieser sensor lösung sind wir jahrzehnte
weg das vertrauen ist kaputt das
vertrauen ist was spielt es wird ich
werde eine vielleicht erlebe ich es noch
bis wir russland mit russland wieder zu
dieser beziehung kommen wie wir sie mal
habe und es liegt doch wissen dass da
haben wir so viel kaputt gemacht aber
wir können jetzt helfe ich etwas anders
an wir können es ist der krieg wird von
uns gehört nein doch er wurde
angezettelt von putin hat seine
interessen oder lässt sich diplomatisch
gesagt wir wollen dass die schüler
geschafft erschaffung bei ihm nicht
jeder hat es einen plan also hitler ist
seinen plan butina zeitplan aber wir
haben
die usa die nato hat beschlossen die
ukraine in die nato aufzunehmen
2008 da hat die kanzlerin damals und
sakura gewalt und gemerkt können doch
jetzt nicht wegen 2008 oder sie dürfen
das natürlich darf man alles aber würden
sie jetzt wegen 2008 die direkte linie
dazu ziehen dass zu den angriffskrieg
gemacht auch es wurden jahre später hat
mehrere male gebeten mit den amerikanern
über minsk 112 zu sprechen die
amerikaner gesagt da reden wir mit ihnen
über gar nicht drüber das war sicherlich
richtig dass ich unbedingt und nicht und
gegraben haben mit einer führung sind
jährigen kultur herumspringen auch opern
denn mit einem land war also wie soll so
wenig wie möglich einfach mimik die
reden wir nicht was hast du denn schon
zu erzählen desto geben mit denen wir
nicht der kommerz damit jeder seine
redezeit hier bekommt einmal zu
und sie dürfen jetzt mit ihrem plädoyer
dass ich auch schon vorher sehr gerne
gelesen habe das gar nicht alles so
schwarz man sitzt er hier an diesem
tisch und merkt bei einem thema gibt es
viele meinungen zum glück haben wir das
ist auch in deutschland
ein plädoyer
ich habe eigentlich gar kein platter ich
bin einfach nur ein tatkräftiger
menschlichen die praktikerin für
möglicherweise bei ganz vielen
theoretikern weil ich im endeffekt
einfach zu packen wenn irgendwas ist ich
habe auch eine ukrainerin die habe ich
seit märz das heißt sie habe ich aber
nicht ich eine ukrainerin aufnehmen
wollte sondern ich habe mich geärgert
dass die ukrainerinnen ihre haustiere
bis zur grenze mitschleppen manchmal
große schäferhunde um die zu retten und
kaum sind sie in den deutschen
aufwarten angekommen müssen die tiere in
das tierheim also habe ich gesagt ich
nehme haustiere auf und ich nehme den
haustieren die entsprechendes das
frauchen auf und egal wer jetzt kommt
und dann kam eben natalia mit zwei
hunden und ihre tochter mit einer katze
und so kam das aus der thalia hat eine
hat eine ballettschule in
kiew und ist jetzt natürlich online
verbunden hat auch ihre eine
ballettschülerinnen bei mir hat sie auch
da trainiert und jetzt waren sie bei der
weltmeisterschaft in san sebastian haben
bei der weltmeisterschaft den vierten
platz geholt da bin ich richtig stolz
auf meine und auf meine ukrainerinnen
denn die anderen die konkurrenz die
hatte natürlich große ballettschulen
haben da richtig
üben können und meine hat bei mir im
wohnzimmer gehört also von dem her
gesehen denke ich immer wenn wir was tun
können können uns jetzt im moment für
die menschen tun denn auch natalia
möchte natürlich zurück alle wollen
zurück aber alle wollen natürlich nicht
dass ihnen eine bombe aufs haus fällt
und bei ihr in käfers jetzt genauso das
500 meter weit eine rakete eingeschlagen
hat und das finde ich eigentlich das
dramatische dass der menschen sitzen die
auf einen knopf drücken und gar nicht
mehr wissen wenn es dann am schluss
eigentlich trifft und dann weiß ich auch
nicht wie das mit dem wiederaufbau sein
soll denn wenn jetzt aufgebaut wird wo
soll aufgebaut werden und bisher ist ja
noch gar nichts befriedet wir wissen ja
noch gar nicht was putin noch weiter
vorhat wieder dann vom don was praktisch
nachdem er dann diese seite für sich
eingenommen hat wunderschön dann
praktisch ins land vormarschieren wenn
er dann diese länge hat werden wir
schauen ja in seinem kopf nicht rein
leider das wäre natürlich wunderschön
ich vergleiche es immer so ein bisschen
wenn jetzt in deutschland einmarschiert
werden würde und man sagt jetzt okay es
geht mir die bayern hat mal ab weil die
haben ja auch zwei grenzen tschechien
und
unterstreichen so wunderbar unterlaufen
bis am bodensee rheinländer wieder
abgeben
vielleicht gar nicht so
auch wehren und würden dann auch sagen
hier läuten wir wollen die bayern aber
doch behalten und wir kämpfen ich zu
hass und die bayern
und von dem er gesehen aber denke ich
ist längst eben auch so land tirol und
südtirol auch damals wurde die grafische
tiroler werden gerne ich
wählen könnte ewig weiter man
kosovo-albaner wollten ihre autonomie
haben und haben diese autonomie auch
bekommen und es gibt gewisse länder die
haben die kosovo-albaner anerkannt und
andere länder auch nicht also diese
autonomiebestrebungen haben wir überall
und das gehört ja zur demokratie
das die leute selber sagen dürfen zu wem
sie gehört oder doch diese zeit gerade
nicht in der ukraine ist halt im moment
was das angeht nein nicht das stimmt so
bin ich und europas im dom was die das
gebiet was die russen jetzt erobern
wollen
dort hat sich die bevölkerung weil sie
auch russisch sprach ich sind und sich
sehr viel mit honig 47 prozent genau
dass das
system versagt nicht alle halten also
sowieso wo sie an sich das verfahren
weiter diese auf halbe halbe oder so
ging der creme haben sie abgestimmt da
war hat man ja eindeutig gesehen was sie
wollen und jetzt dort las man sie doch
auch abstürze kommen und vielleicht will
ja auch lemberg und der west ukraine
wollen vielleicht wieder zurück nach
polen könnte auch sein bleiben wir gehen
als und alle alten grenzen
das wäre
dann natürlich nicht schön das ist ein
grobes unrecht wenn ein land ein anderes
silberfeld und grenzen verschiedener
überhaupt keine frage aber die frage ist
ja was passiert dann was macht man dann
kann man das verhindern kann man es
hätte man es vielleicht im vorhinein
verhindern können auch wir machen also
ich glaube da hat das wort bessere
diplomatie und politik diesen ganzen
flug verfluchten krieg der schon so
viele menschenleben gekostet dann hätte
verhindern können so das ist jetzt
vergossene milch aber es ist trotzdem
eine relevante frage weil das auch mit
verantwortung heißt aber wenn man ihn
schon nicht verhindern konnte wie kann
man jetzt möglichst schnell das sterben
beenden und natürlich ist es auch nicht
die einzige region auf dieser welt die
die besetzt wird auch in den letzten
jahren nicht mehr also die usa zum
beispiel besetzen bis heute die
syrischen ölfelder große teile davon das
finden die völlig normal die haben uns
nochmal da irgendwie so ein wort
umgebaut und schaffen das öl weg die
türkei besetzt und wird auch immer
wieder kriegerisch tätig sowohl in
syrien als auch im nord-irak überfällt
er einfach bestimmte regionen einerseits
große relativierungen das ist nicht das
eine sein also von das andere doch auch
mal was hierzu aus
ihrer partei geführt hat sie ihre
haltung dass man diese verhandlungen
diese gespräche jetzt aufnehmen muss und
sollte und ein nein nein nein schallt
ihnen dahingegen stadträte nicht die
position einer bar in der partei ich
vertrete meine position
aber das ist
die einzig einige hier zu sagen wenn nur
deutschland bereit ist vielleicht mit
frankreich zusammen den schalter
umzulegen dann wird das alles gut und
auch nico rosberg
und was mich nervt also wie gesagt das
ist keine relativierung nur ich finde
man sollte nicht so tun als ob der
einzige grauenvolle verbrecherische
krieg seit dem ende des zweiten
weltkriegs in der ukraine stattfinden ob
das einzige grobe unrecht wo mit
waffengewalt gebiete und grenzen
verschoben werden in der ukraine
stattfindet das stimmt nicht es gab ganz
viele kriege gerade auch in den letzten
jahren gerade auch unter führung der usa
aber hat er haben wir auch nie mit
sanktionen reagiert und
natur des menschen umso näher es beim
ist im freundeskreis betrifft seien
deswegen möchte ich auf den krieg
hinweisen unter freunden unser
gemeinsamer freunde prinz asserate der
in frankfurt lebt hat mich gestern
darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass in seinem
krieg in seinem land äthiopien der
schlimmste kriegt und jetzt seit 3000
jahren
die bringen im massenmorden in der
frankfurter allgemeine haben sie so viel
text darüber das ist wirklich zum weinen
in der schlimmste krieg sagt er seit
3000 jahren ein altes kulturvolk wo sich
zwei natürlich wird es auch von
irgendjemandem mitfinanzierte wissen
nicht wer ich weiß es nie wer hin
dahinter steckt aber er sagt
abgeschlachtet auf abertausende von
menschen und glas wieder überhaupt nicht
darüber sprechen sie sprechen leute aber
das ist nicht weit ist ist neben an der
front wir sind doch während der
globalisierung ununterbrochen nach
südafrika gefahren nach indien gefahren
nach amerika gewarnt das ist viel weiter
weg als äthiopien ist nächste was möchte
ich das nicht relativieren jetzt mit ihr
bin ich finde es ganz schlimm auch wenn
das nirgendwo berichtet wird ich habe
leider auch noch nichts darüber aktuell
gelesen dementsprechend gebe ich ihnen
recht aber dieser krieg in europa da ist
man ja schon auch als deutscher
aufgewacht und konnte es kaum fassen
dass er wieder krieg in europa haben
weil wir nicht auf die kanzlerin weil
die kanzlerin und sarkozy weil man nicht
ihnen geholfen hat wahrscheinlich hat
damals die presse auch wieder geschimpft
dass sie nicht zu hören dass george hw
bush dass der recht hat und man muss
jetzt streng sein aber das ist und man
muss ja durchsetzen was wahrheit ist
leute ich noch letzte woche
textanzeigen nur mit stärke können wir
denen da müssen wir jetzt richtig ran
solch eine rhetorik von deutschland
ausgerechnet deutsche und ausgerechnet
die grünen unsere friedenspartei die
leute die bäume umrahmen also leute wir
müssen wieder nüchtern werden wir müssen
wieder sagen die deutschen und die
franzosen wir haben im großen spiel der
weltmächte sowieso kein wirkliches
zünglein an der waage haben wir sind wir
sind conti penible muss man leider sagen
was entgegen könnten einfluss nehmen
weil wir charmante politikerinnen haben
jetzt müssen sie meine ganze reihe
dieser haltung an gut aussehen aber
nicht frau wahnsinnig zum beispiel aber
auch unsere frau bär burg kann könnte
wenn man hier die reifen die in sachen
plaudertasche die ist
die wer mitmachen guten job ja aber
sieht man müsste hier nur sagen was sie
sagen sollen jetzt ist geeicht worden
darauf müsse das seien mit dem russen
man sie soll deren charme einsetzen und
dem coaching bei ihnen nähmen und gerade
sie bereit und dann wir musik washington
verhandelt das sind unsere partner
wir sind diejenigen die die waffen
liefern wir sind diejenigen die gas
geben in diesem krieg wir sind
diejenigen die anschieben macht weiter
macht weiter das muss zu ende sein wir
müssen wieder normal werden wir müssen
sagen wir wollen keinen krieg und schon
gleich gar nicht mit dem ukrainer weil
die uns am herzen liegen für weil uns
die bilder dieser zerstörten häuser
stören weil uns die massen von menschen
die kommen und nach hause wollen wir
ertragen ist nicht bitte hört auf ihr
habt doch auch in afghanistan aufgehört
ihr habt eure ganzen spielsachen
dagelassen die chinesen sich einfach
genommen haben und jetzt schön nachbauen
ihr habt doch auch in afghanistan tolle
sachen einfach stehen lassen doch auch
hier alles schnell sein nein das kannst
du dir so in die nationen
müssen wir nicht gewöhnt aber frau
hauptmann konnte die füßchen sie denn in
diesem man kann sich einerseits
leidenschaftliches plädoyer mehr
überzeugen aber weil für mich ist es ja
immer noch so dass ist es das ist
wunderbar aber
wer geht denn jetzt eigentlich zu herrn
putin und sagt okay jetzt es hat ja
schon jeder versucht
das ganze angezettelt hat beim
drehen wenn wir zurückschauen gebe ich
ihnen völlig recht dass wir da fehler
gemacht haben ganz hundertprozentig wir
haben ja gerade schon mal so nebenher
gesagt eben auch diese diese aussage von
obama das ist ja nur eine russische
provinz odernheim regionalmacht ja das
waren sicherlich kränkungen und kleine
männer mit großen hunden haben probleme
mit kränker ist kann man kann sich so
einfach machen aber es ja auch leute wie
horst teltschik immerhin der gefeierte
architekten der deutschen einheit der
langjährige chef für mich eine
sicherheitskonferenz der in einem
interview schon nach ausbruch des
krieges um die ukraine gesagt hat es war
ein fehler dass wir nach der
sicherheitskonferenz damals vielleicht
mehr putin dort zum letzten mal zu gast
in münchen und seine sorgen und auch
seine drohung öffentlich gemacht hat
nicht darauf eingegangen sind so was
versandet natürlich völlig untätig ist
ja wirklich nicht im verdacht irgendwie
russen freundlich oder dergleichen zu
sagen dass ich ganz erreicht ich weiß ja
dass das unheimlich aufbaut und
irgendwann dann dann platzt das und
jetzt wollte halt eben auch mal zeigen
wie gesagt kränkungen sind
leuchtern und frau trotzdem ich glaube
auch mit italien und wem auch immer
zusammen hier
gemeinsam sich an einen tisch setzen
könnten mit vladimir putin um den großen
frieden oder das aufheben der sanktionen
zu erreichen das halte ich für so was
von illusorisch gerade nach den
entwicklungen die wir gesehen haben hier
braucht es dann eine eine gesamte straße
weil jetzt verschiedene dinge also den
krieg zu beenden da braucht das die usa
nie sagen sie wohnen in einem zonen auf
die eben nicht nur allein dort all die
länder die sich an den sanktionen nicht
beteiligen haben mit russland normale
wirtschaftsbeziehungen da liefern die
ihr laster liefern die
sie liefern auch wie gesagt in die
türkei sie liefern auch nach ungarn sie
liefern an all die länder die jetzt
sagen sie wollen gerne kaufen und sie
machen da nicht mit das ist ja schon so
also weiß ich auch nicht verstanden habe
das ist tatsächlich so dass ist die
strategie die wir haben seit anfang der
sanktionen zu sagen ja wir bestrafen die
ich wladimir putin nicht auch von
unserer außenministerin und auch in
unserem wirtschaftsminister und wir
drehen der das gas ab und wir stoßen
auch die öllieferung auf null aber
vorher machst du uns noch mal die
gasspeicher voll ich das ist ja
natürlich nicht mehr kauft wir wollen
nicht mehr kaufen aber vorher noch mal
voll machen dass das ohne folgen bleibt
ist natürlich genauso klar dass das
nicht funktionieren kann ich meine das
würde auch jeder unternehmer also nehme
an ich bin unternehmer und will einen
lieferanten loswerden weil der mir
irgendwie zu anstrengend ist ja dann
gehe ich doch nicht erst erste szenen
sagt dem lieferanten also dich werde ich
auf jeden fall ab nächstes jahr werde
ich nichts mehr von der cau und aber ich
habe noch gar keinen anderen wäre mir
was lief
da guckt man sich doch vorher um was
haben wir für alternativen man hätte man
natürlich auch bei erneuerbaren sicher
manches mehr machen können man hätte
vielleicht auch in andere richtungen
gucken können wo man alternativen hat
wenn sie bezahlbar sind und wenn wir sie
haben dann hätten wir ja auch sagen okay
dann reduzieren wir die russischen
lieferungen aber was die deutsche
regierung gemacht hat war einfach
kompletter wahnsinn also sie haben im
grunde angekündigt ende des jahres
wollen sie auch wie das russische öl
nicht mehr und das gas weiß ich nicht
ein paar jahren und dann gehen sie davon
aus aber bis dahin liefern die brav
möglichst auch noch zu den guten alten
verträgen mit sehr niedrigen preisen das
war ja ist ja tatsächlich im märz auf
von ist dank der niedrigen preise
hier geht mit einem blau pulver
unterbrechung und kommt dann zum thema
wo vielleicht mehr einheit jan tisch
herrscht und das ist corona bist gleich
was hast doch waren wunderschön
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen die damen und herren
bei 14 85 köpfen sind meinungen jeder
von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht was
ihn bewegt freut oder schockiert
so nicht
herr jörges wetten das auge ist aber
niemand von den politischen parteien
traut sich zu sagen ja das wollen wir
einfach nur freiheit diese grün-roten
der damen führen hochtrabende debatten
über die rettung des weltklimas und
kommen die füße russland die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
afg zu überlassen lasst den leuten noch
mal einen spaß wir sehen ja etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
durch das tragen eines party zum manko
leicht einmal kurz einsatz also immer
noch das unmögliche andrack träger
ausgesprochen in bewegung bringen ich
habe meinen beifall über eine sache
immer bekommt er kümmert sich darum
niemand wird es bald den inserat ist er
ganz klar nein auch darüber sprechen das
ist einfach nicht fertig richtig wo ist
die aufgabe von journalismus einfach die
verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück mit der these von béla
anda
janina rasen etwas ganz anderes aber
auch sehr aktuell corona wir rasen im
blindflug in den nächsten corona
lockdown und machen die gleichen fehler
die in den letzten jahren denn
deutschlandweit steigen die zahlen aus
interessanterweise im osten deutschlands
aber die inzidenz in den westen auch im
saarland steigen und steigen einig sind
sich wieder mal fast alle über die
konsequenzen für den kommenden herbst
währenddessen
gilt es nach den befürwortern der korona
maßnahme masten pflicht in innenräumen
auf jeden fall auch einen lock down in
schulen will gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach nicht ausschließen
währenddessen kommunizieren die
gesundheitsämter immer noch per fax und
was ist eigentlich geworden aus dem
ganzen lüftungsanlagen in unseren
schulen aus dem digitalisierungsbericht
auf home office für alle das sollte doch
mal eine dauerhafte institution werden
alles schall und rauch schon fordern die
ersten wieder ein bundesweites register
oder den vierten peaks den bundeskanzler
inklusive also die vierte impfung wobei
völlig unklar ist ob die hilft gegen die
neuen varianten
den berühmten b a4 und a5 oder ganz neu
bei 75 neue varianten des corona virus
ich meine es braucht kein anhaltenden
kontrollwahn es braucht auch keine neue
masken pflicht ist braucht auch keinen
neuen locker und für schulen was es
braucht ist mehr eigenverantwortung wir
sehen doch schon jetzt dass in
öffentlichen räumen viele menschen
wieder mit masken unterwegs sind weil
sie sich selber schützen wollen weil sie
auch diese eigenverantwortung tragen was
in zwei jahren pandemie nicht besser
wurde das wird auch im dritten jahr
nicht besser und deswegen im gegenteil
die menschen haben gelernt sich selbst
zu vertrauen und sich selber zu schützen
deswegen bin ich dafür gebt den menschen
das kommando denn wenigstens sie wissen
was sie tun frau wagenknecht ist denn
mit einem gesundheitsminister macht das
überhaupt möglich dass die bürger das
kommando zurück erhalten da kann man
ernsthafte zweifel daran haben war
natürlich kann ja bitte
gesundheitsminister alleine ja auch
nicht alles machen also letztlich muss
das die bundesregierung beschließen und
wenn die fdp ausnahmsweise zudem stehe
was sie so ankündigen dann müsste das
eigentlich klar sein dass es im herbst
nicht nochmal solchen unsinn gibt wie 2g
und 3g oder gar schulschließungen und
ähnliches ich meine jetzt auch der der
sachverständigenausschuss dem hat man ja
ausdrücklich die aufgabe gegeben er soll
evaluieren wie die maßnahmen gewirkt
hatte lauterbach gesagt das gutachten
darf jetzt auch kein bremsklotz sein hat
er ja ich finde als ich finde das eine
frechheit ich meine da sind da ist eine
gruppe von wissenschaftlern und die
arbeiten meines wissens seit märz 21
also wirklich eine sehr lange zeit und
das sind ja renommierte kluge leute so
und dann gibt es nach fast anderthalb
jahren so ein bericht der ausdrücklich
erwünscht wurde und der bericht war
jetzt sicherlich nicht so wie lauterbach
sich das vorgestellt hat weil es war ja
klar also die meisten maßnahmen sind
durchgefallen und außerdem wurde noch
mal sehr deutlich kritisiert dass wir in
deutschland eine daten höchste haben
also dass wir eigentlich gar nichts
wissen wir wissen nicht wie viele leute
sind wirklich infiziert wir wissen nicht
wie viele sind wegen corona im
krankenhaus wir wissen bis heute nicht
wie viele menschen sterben an corona
also es ist eigentlich eine katastrophe
so und das haben wir die diese
wissenschaftler sehr klar gesagt und
haben gesagt ja gut wenn man jetzt etwas
sinnvolles machen will muss man die
datenlage verbessern aber ansonsten ist
völlig klar also 2g 3g hat schon deshalb
keinen sinn weil die impfung ja keinen
schutz gibt gegen infektionen das heißt
was für mich daraus folgt ist auch das
schleunigst diese einrichtungs bezogen
pflicht abgeschafft werden muss also die
einrichtungs bezogen nebenpflicht also
die haben mir immer noch nah so dass
leute die in gesundheitseinrichtungen
arbeiten die haben das damoklesschwert
und teilweise wird das ja auch
praktiziert das sie gekündigt werden
weil sie nicht geimpft sind obwohl die
garantiert auch selber chocolat
vielleicht ein oder zwei mal durch rang
nach osten ja ist es völlig unsinnig so
und deswegen finde ich also wann darf
hierbei lauterbach nicht machen lassen
ich erwarte dass man dieses gutachten
ernst nimmt und ich hoffe sehr dass das
wofür sie auch plädieren wirklich im
herbst eintritt also wer eine maske
tragen möchte der kann die doch tragen
ist doch überhaupt kein problem ob man
sind sie für die einrichtungs bezogen im
schlecht
also ich bin da so ein bisschen hin- und
hergerissen
ich bin geimpft ich sehe für mich auch
wirklich alles richtig und alles gut ich
werde mir auch die vierte impfungen
geben lassen es so weit ist dann ich bin
65 und ab 60 sollte man schon ein
bisschen auf sich aufpassen dass ich
natürlich trotzdem überträger sein kann
ist ganz klar also aber ich bin da
egoistisch ich will einfach durch dass
es mich trifft denn ich habe einige im
bekanntenkreis die an longo wie bleiben
junge leute und wenn man das mal sieht
was war passiert wenn die zwei treppen
hoch gehen und vorher waren sie tolle
sportler und die kommen noch kaum die
treppe hoch da denke ich mir selbst
gesagt jeder kann übertragen ja
eigentlich schutz argument ja eigentlich
weg oder also doch also im endeffekt
also ich stütze mich ganz so einfach
gefühle mir leid macht er ja selber
entscheiden das ist einfach nur
egoistische haltung von mir dass ich
meine ich finde ja ich werde irgendwann
lassen möchte gerade ältere menschen
dem sollte man die vierte impfung
anbieten die datenlage ist da meines
erachtens relativ unklar ob sie hilft
oder nicht aber wer das für sich möchte
der sollte das auch können also
überhaupt alle branchen nicht mehr aber
niemand sollte der druck gesetzt was sie
nicht mehr passieren darf ist ein lock
down also das hat das haben wir jetzt
gesehen das ist ja wirklich auch für
unsere wirtschaft das war ja das war ja
furchtbar also auch wir wir künstler und
selbstständige wir haben ja da wirklich
wahnsinnig darunter gelitten alle alle
tragen dass er noch ein bisschen hinter
sich her also da bin ich auch voll der
meinung also locker und geht überhaupt
nicht um den schulen auch nicht weil die
die jetzt das abitur gemacht haben ich
meine ich werde euch gefallen muss
ehrlich sagen wenn ich ein jahr lang nur
online irgendwie was ich hätte das
abitur habe ich geschafft und von dem er
gesehen denke ich mir sind die
wirklichen 18 das ungerechteste abitur
das scheint ja das kommt sie zu masken
pflicht beim sport nicht meine das gab
es ja alles die kinder ganztagsschulen
von morgens acht bis nachmittags um vier
mit masken in der schule und unter
gleichen also obwohl ist es gab auch
davor und weiß nicht und dann bei über
zwei jahre lang und wenn es wieder
anfangen soll oder wieder lockt downs
oder wieder der gleichen oder oder in
schulen dann
fernunterricht sein soll dann muss man
sagen dann haben wir was wirklich falsch
gemacht aber nochmals zurück ich frage
mich wirklich was mit diesen ganzen
maßnahmen ist ja angekündigt worden von
den luftfiltern bis hin zur
digitalisierung gibt es das jetzt gibt
es das nicht wie datenaustausch über den
gesundheitsämtern das war teilweise so
und dies offenbar immer noch so dass die
daten per fax übermittelt worden und
dann von einer excel-tabelle die man im
eigenen computer hatten aber nicht
übertragen werden durften dann hände
darüber schreiben wurden abgeschrieben
gewachst dann war das fax papier nicht
da oder mussten sie mit der post
transportiert werden also
vorsintflutlich ungefähr zu ein bisschen
die bestandsaufnahme wo stehen wir da
jetzt und sind wir jetzt schon weiter
wir immer wieder versprochen wurde oder
eben auch nicht also ich finde auch ein
thema ist nach wie vor und ich finde es
skandalös dass da lauterbach eben auch
überhaupt nichts gemacht hat das ist der
pflegenotstand also die situation in
krankenhäusern ist ja wirklich schlimm
also für die pflegekräfte weil es
einfach zu wenige gibt also umso
schlimmer ist es dass man noch einigen
den stuhl vor die tür setzt weil sie
nicht geimpft sind und andere gehen weil
sie jeweils sie ausgebrannt sind und in
nrw wird gestreikt seit wochen für
bessere arbeitsbedingungen und es
passiert nichts und das finde ich auch
ganz schlimm weil natürlich wenn man
sieht dass krankenhäuser und immer
weniger personal ist dass die
katastrophale arbeitsbedingungen haben
dass sie natürlich auch viel zu wenig
verdienen für die schwere arbeit die sie
machen dann ist doch völlig klar dass es
im herbst wieder notsituation geben wird
ich habe vor kurzem ihr im bericht
angeguckt da hat man gedacht dass wir
aus der korona zeit da wo war eine
ard-bericht
operationen verschoben
notstand alle notaufnahmen dicht und
dann habe ich geguckt von waren war der
von 2018 in der krippe werde also das
ist schon damals so gewesen und wir
schauen dazu und dann wird immer so
getan ja jetzt müssen wir aber doch auf
jeden fall freiheits einschränkungen
machen weil sonst können die die
situation in krankenhäusern ja nicht
wieder im griff können wir nicht in den
griff kriegen nein wir müssen die
bessere pflege bessere
arbeitsbedingungen schaffen bessere
löhne dann gibt es auch genügend
ausgebildete pfleger in deutschland
übrigens die arbeit nur in anderen jobs
und wurden teilweise ja gibt es
untersuchungen also es gibt eine
befragung die hat werd ich mal gemacht
die hatte und das war noch direkt vor
gewinner das waren 3 1000 leute also
dich alle befragt aber die ihren job in
den letzten jahren verlassen haben
ausgebildete pfleger die haben eine
repräsentativbefragung unter solchen
leuten gemacht und da kam raus die
hälfte würde in ihrer arbeit
zurückkehren als pfleger wenn die
arbeitsbedingung anders wäre aber
eigentlich ständig gefordert wäre
wahnsinnig da können wir uns glaube ich
das ist das schöne ich glaube wir können
die sendung so ändern dass wir alle uns
bessere bedingungen für die pflege
wünschen und damit sind wir auch am ende
angekommen entscheiden sie morgen abend
wieder ein wenn es heißt für den schönen
abend noch
[Musik]